it was a chance thing and I don't even
remember her name I wonder if my parents
remember that name one second ma hey
what's up G Q this is Troye Sivan I am
coming to you from isolation in my
parents house in Melbourne and today I'm
gonna go undercover on the Internet it's
actually me seriously it's actually me
okay so the first place I'm gonna log on
is Laura and we've got a question here
what is Troye Sivan like in real life I
reckon I'm like pretty quiet in real
life I have like two friends total in
the world and I like that way I can get
a little bit quiet and like group
situations and stuff really like being
with my family really like being with my
friends really like being with my dog
but hopefully people would say I'm like
nice that's like my goal in life
next question where McCory is how is cos
if I'm constantly I would write catchy
hidden music first of all I've never
written it in my life I'm skinny um I
don't really strive for like hip music
that's never really been what's driven
me
I just want to connect with people on a
real real real level you know maybe get
them to think about their life and their
situation in a way that they've never
thought about it before I think that's
the main goal but thank you very much
that's very very nice of you
why did twice abundance stop making as
many YouTube videos these honestly I
just got over it if it feels genuine and
exciting to me hopefully it's gonna feel
genuine and exciting to everyone else so
I'm like okay you know what I'm not
gonna like fake it this is not exciting
to me anymore let me go do something
that's actually exciting and like
hopefully you guys will still be along
for the ride you know Troye Sivan got
catfished by someone pretending to be
Greta thumb bag what timeline are we
living in this was the most insane thing
that's ever happened to me my entire
life
basically my manager got reached out to
buy great fun bags dad and then it turns
out that it was actually these like
Russian hackers pretending to be better
on Wednesday which was cool and awesome
and also hilarious like I died laughing
I think it's the funniest thing about
they still have my number every now and
then I'll get a text from like Greta
thumb bag let's just be like hey what's
up how I it's great
who do you think is the most underrated
artist right now poof that's a good
question should I go into my Spotify I
have my
top right here I mean listening to you
know I'm excited about I've only ever
had one song Charli XCX sinusitis called
Elio and she's got the song out called
my friends online that I really really
like so I'm very someone says he looks
sassy 100%
I am sassy I mean the screenshot that
I'm seeing here is from the bloom video
which is probably me at my sassiest I
was on a journey that day to feel really
feeling myself I was blond freshly
freshly bleep full face and makeup I
don't care I think it was why does he
look like Scarlett Johansson's male
version I take that as a huge huge
compliment
thank you she's Jewish I didn't know me
that she's like such a surprise Jewish
person to me and I'm Jewish so I take
great great pride in that compliment
thank you very much somebody says oh my
god does anyone remember the slide
movies no and for good reason next
question so when I was like 14 15 16 17
I got cast in like like I don't want to
talk it but it was sort of like so
everything a Harry Potter and I went and
I made these movies the first ones
alright don't watch the rest Troy take
your cell phone me raising awareness in
a worldwide pandemic to shelter in place
stay at home I'm not gonna lie this was
a complete accident
I wrote take yourself home a good few
months ago well before the effects of
coma 19 it just felt like the right time
to release it and it also is called take
your cell phone which like everybody
should be doing if you can be doing so
hot catchy pop song hot yes it's very
chic back to Cora what is voices on his
haircut name
honestly like don't even look at this I
was so tempted to put on a hat today I'm
sure you guys have seen worse because
everyone's in quarantine but not having
access to address those it's not doing
me any favors at the moment it's kind of
like a like a curly moppy mullet let's
call it that the curly my fila well say
that five times fast
curly mocking Mallicoat nope nevermind
okay another question from Cora how do
you think of choice events music and his
view
I just want like in 15 years 20 years 30
years 40 years oh did you hear that
twice fun released a new blank that
should be cool or at least actually
interesting you know like I just want to
keep people on their toes so you get an
album or a like furniture line I have no
idea I just want people to like trust me
you know what I mean and be like okay
cool he's like acting with integrity and
that's like all I really want in life I
think supply where people listen Chikara
is my number one city in the world
Jakarta Indonesia I've been there I
really really liked it Sydney Australia
hell yeah how do you say this quais own
city quite Sun City in the Philippines
what's up Singapore and Chicago I think
I've been to all of these places except
for quite as on the city but I have been
to the Philippines that I loved it there
and now it feels kind of like a crazy
fever dream to think about touring like
it feels like I can't believe we ever
did that and it's only been like a month
of the self-isolation thing but I really
really can't wait to can you imagine how
lik the world is gonna be like after
this quarantine when we all get to like
be together in big groups and just like
celebrate life and music and like get
drunk with each other all these things
that we took for granted I'm very very
excited to hit the road again and my
first stop is going to be Jakarta
Indonesia Twitter Troye Sivan played
young Logan in x-men origins Wolverine
yeah I did that was my first ever
audition so I was just a singer on
YouTube like I used to upload videos of
me singing these random little zones and
then a manager found me and he was like
hey I like what I see but I'm not used
to manager I don't know what to do with
that have you ever tried acting before
and at the time I hadn't and he was like
can I send you some auditions is that
cool and the first one he ever said to
me was to play young Wolverine in x-men
origins Wolverine my parents at the time
we my dad was at the shopping centre I'm
getting you a long story when I was at
the shopping center and this girl came
up to him and she was like hey do you
know where I can like is there any
hotels or anything nearby and he was
like wait what why and she's like
because I'm sleeping in my car and from
Canada and my dad was like are you
Jewish cuz he could just like tell from
the vibes and she was like yeah I am and
he was like do you need a place to stay
I swear I'm not crazy these are my like
for children this is my wife we live
wherever we live here's my GPS drive to
our house and you can
you have to sleep in your car she came
over now it was time for me to film this
audition and I had no idea how to film
anything like I had never edited before
I never felt before and she was like oh
I'm a film student I know exactly how to
do all of this [ __ ] and so me my mom and
this stranger sat down filmed an
audition I was like acting for the first
time had no idea what I was doing
she helped me like editor exponent we
sent it off and then two weeks later I
found out that I got the path and then I
was in x-men movie it was a chance thing
and I don't even remember her name
I wonder if my parents remember that
name one second okay so apparently it
might be Lara that's like all we've got
so far but we'll do some detective work
and we're gonna find out Instagram
[Music]
someone says what's your son's name and
put it with my beautiful beautiful man
his name is Nash this is so sort of hard
to be away from him to this phone purely
because I don't know when I'm ex gonna
see him and it's like actually breaking
my heart I said goodbye to him before I
went to Atlanta I was shooting a movie
there and then the movie got put on
pause and I flew to Australia and now
like God knows when I'm gonna be able to
leave so I just wish I could like talk
to him and explain can you imagine if I
could just like send him a text and be
like hey Nash Lee it's me just to let
you know there's like a global pandemic
I don't know when I'm Rex gonna see you
but I promise I think about you every
second of every day I would love to send
in that message
witnesses what's your favorite is
already excited you know I know
absolutely nothing about zodiac signs
like people always ask me what I am and
then to be polite I ask them what they
are as if I like have any idea what any
of it means and don't really know and to
be honest like don't really care I don't
know that I believe in it but I'm in
Gemini and I guess my favorite zodiac
sign is Leo divided two of my family and
I like them what's your favorite Disney
movie hmm my favorite mom when I was a
kid was always speculated speaking you
right yeah I think that was my favorite
when I was like young I haven't watched
learn in a while but yeah Hercule also
is um Coco is that Disney
I love that movie so much I cried a lot
Paul is Troye Sivan louder than bums
it's written by Troye Sivan so this is a
cool story my like writing crude the
crew that I wrote youth with the crew
that I work bite with the cruiser I
wrote like so many of my songs with the
first song we ever ever ever wrote
together at the time it was called
hologram hearts terrible terrible title
and we wrote it and I was like oh cool I
actually really like writing with these
people this was really fun and so he
kept writing the next time we wrote it
was like when we were at youth or
something like that and we sat on this
song for like six years
hologram hats completely completely
forgot about it somehow it got into the
hands of the BTS boys who I love and
they loved to song and they were like
wait we're gonna cut this and I freaked
out quickly tried to learn Korean failed
miserably so many times they ended it
and I guess I've changed some lyrics and
stuff like that and now it's called
louder than bombs but I didn't hear it
until it was out in the world so I was
like up at midnight or whenever that
album came out and refreshing refreshing
with like the rest of the world because
everyone is obsessed as they should be
and now I have a song on the BTS album
and I'm really excited about it and I
love it and they sound so good like so
much better than I ever sounded on that
song so I'm happy
does anyone know choice runs shoe size
why I know my shoe size it's seven I
think in men's in Australian I don't
know are they different
like his Australian shoe size is
different from American shoe sizes I'm a
seven I think in American or Australian
I don't really know sorry
so I guess no one knows my shoe size if
I don't know my shoe size he does Troy
how are you feeling I feel pretty good I
feel a little cooped up today problem
from the cabin fever but I also just
feel like an overwhelming sense of
gratitude it is I think what has come
from the spirit of isolation for me like
the fact that isolation and Quarantine
and like me surviving this time is
literally just me going back to my
parents house and being like a kid again
my mom like makes me every meal and like
riced in here to make my bed before I
film this so I'm extremely extremely
lucky and so I just like have been very
conscious of that for the last two weeks
wait wait wait
did I hear Troy say he was somewhere
filming a movie yes you did it hasn't
been announced yet so I thought you know
it did I can talk about it so I'm not
going to but I'm
I'm really really excited about it the
producers who made like Juvenal and up
in the air and all of these incredible
movies which are like two of my top five
movies of all time just don't tell
anyone I told you but yeah it's gonna be
cool thank you so much Internet and
thank you so much GQ for those
insightful questions I hope you learned
a little something just a quick reminder
if you buy a take yourself home t-shirt
we've got three that are all designed by
incredible designers from all over the
world and if you buy one 100% of the
proceeds go in a co-ed relief so if
we're still in this crazy time and we're
still in this lockdown please consider
doing that if you want a cute t-shirt
and you want to help people
otherwise stay at home if you can stay
safe I hope you're all okay I love you
laughs I'll see you soon